today's episode is brought to you by the
US Army you love the original trilogy
with a burning passion you went to war
over the last Jedi now get ready for a
completely new kind of Star Wars movie
when you'll forget by the time you're
home from the theater solo a Star Wars
story oh yeah that did come out this
year didn't it after Disney we shot half
of their first Star Wars story because
they didn't like what the director did
watch them hand the keys to an exciting
new creative team then reshoot even more
of the movie because they didn't like
what the directors did not touch e
resulting in a mixed bag that wasn't
exactly great but wasn't exactly
terrible and if that's how Disney plans
to bring balance to the force
just sit me up fam prepare for a
feature-length adaptation of Han Solo's
will he PD a page in a film that's less
a han Solo character study and more of
an origin story for all of Han Solo's
accessories like his gun his ship the
Millennium Falcon
the little nudge in his ship his
favorite comeback I hate you and of
course his iconic dice
since when were the dye such a big deal
it was just a silly background prop not
everything needs an explanation I don't
have people come on
solo
no one asked for this gear up with Alden
Ehrenreich a good young actor stuff with
a thankless job of playing a young
Harrison Ford I waited a long time for a
shot like this I'm not about to screw it
up all right he'll add new dimensions to
the selfish outlaw pilot we met a new
hope by showing us he was never much of
an outlaw
he was a guy and he was never really
that selfish but boy did he have a
hard-on for being a pilot I'm gonna be a
pilot I'm gonna be pilot this order
myself have become a pilot I'm a great
pilot I'll be your co-pilot we've
already got the pilot okay okay he wants
to be a pilot we get it already
anything else what was his dad like he
wanted to be a pilot
uh-uh never mind let's just go back to
learning about his accessories where'd
he get that vest strap in as Han joins a
gang of even scruffier nerf herders like
Chewbacca
who eats people now Beckett who acts a
lot like Woody Harrelson if he got
trapped in a Star Wars movie Kyra who's
working for Paul Bettany but really
working with Han but really working with
Darth Maul
he gave triple cross the double cross he
can trim across a double cross Wow the
coolest new Star Wars character is
nevermind Lando the Star Wars story we'd
all rather see except for that part
where he's clearly having sex with this
droid X and L 337 who is either an sjw
or an offensive satire bloke this
depending on which part of the internet
you like to scream at when han Solo was
the blandest character in your hunt so a
movie you've got a problem I'm hot
nobody cares did you want a darker take
on the Star Wars franchise well you've
got it because this one is so dark it's
hard to see what's happening whether the
action is hidden in deep blues muted
Browns a kind of drab olive or Taco Bell
beep orange by the time your eyes adjust
you'll realize everyone in the galaxy is
lit like they're in witness protection
oh cool there's the Falcon I think man
this movie is literally the dark side
so catch the first flop of the Disney
Star Wars era that froze all the other
standalone projects in carbonite but
gave fans a sense of how Honda came the
character we all know and love by going
through the events of solo then at some
point off-camera before a new hub
becoming the character we all know and
love that could setting heard about this
very big gangster put together a job so
what was the point of moving again
starring Lone Star Harry and the
Harrisons white man can't jump to
Lightspeed Khaleesi the sentient being
trapped inside the Falcon yikes six
seasons and a Wookiee I want Andy named
this character you can't can you Pirates
of the Karelian Samus Aran teras kasi
that krabby PlayStation game is canon
now
knock out half the ball I used to be and
Disney everytime they fire director in
the middle of a production he had a
really good feeling about this
cowboy beef lob
solo you know if so isn't his birth name
why did he give it to his kid and the
name him after Luke's hermit friend who
he knew for like a day maybe no wonder
he tossed him off that bridge today's
episode was brought to you by the u.s.
army find out more by clicking the link
below
what's the matter Colonel Sanders
chicken the watermelon is a Sioux an
explosion a day keeps the Michaels at
bay what makes a hero punching an old
lady in the face